eine echte herausforderung und eine
tolle herausforderung mit riesigem
potenzial etwas bekannt für
umweltfreundlichen verkehr ist lang
[Musik]
wir sind mitten in einer globalen
industriellen revolution
war schutz der umwelt und das
wohlergehen aller stellen uns vor
besondere technologische
herausforderungen mit hochdruck und
leidenschaft arbeiten wissenschaftler
daran eine bessere welt zu gestalten
das tool für meine kinder ich bin davon
überzeugt dass das der richtige weg ist
eine saubere welt
in zukunft gibt es bessere methoden als
das verbrennen fossiler brennstoffe eine
grünere welt
dieser windpark produziert mehr strom
als alle windparks in großbritannien und
wahrscheinlich auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
was wir bisher gemacht haben wird nicht
mehr reichen es geht bessere wege wir
müssen jetzt einen schritt nach vorne
machen und neue technologien einsetzen
arbeit
gemeinsam gehen sie an die grenzen der
wissenschaft um außergewöhnliche
maschinen zu erschaffen die unseren
planeten schützen können für die zukunft
[Musik]
wenn sie irgendwo hin wollen schreiben
ihnen die fluggesellschaften vor von
welchem flughafen sie starten und wann
und auf welchem sie landen sie müssen
sich danach richten
ist das in ökologischer hinsicht
nachhaltig
[Musik]
die eu hat vorher gesagt dass der anteil
der luftfahrt an den globalen co2
emissionen bis 2050 von 2 auf 20 prozent
wachsen wird
[Musik]
es darf nicht sein dass die
luftfahrtindustrie einen so großen
anteil an der co2 bilanz und am
energieverbrauch
[Musik]
steve wright hat 25 jahre lang an
einigen der größten luftfahrt projekte
weltweit gearbeitet
jetzt hilft er die nächste generation
von luft und raumfahrt ingenieuren
auszubilden er kennt die
herausforderungen die sich daraus
ergeben ohne fossile brennstoffe
abzuheben
[Musik]
für kohlenwasserstoff kraftstoff war die
letzten 150 jahre lang ein geschenk
gottes an luftfahrtingenieure wie mich
lassen sie mich das in zahlen ausdrücken
so gewöhnlicher treibstoff hat etwa 40
megajoule energie pro kilogramm
fest dass kur für die feinschmecker
produziert die gute alte natur schmalz
mit 37 megajoule pro kilogramm
dynamit hat nur sechs megajoule pro
kilogramm es ist allerdings sehr gut
darin diese energie blitzartig
freizusetzen
aber jetzt lassen sie uns über batterien
sprechen heutige batterien haben
wahrscheinlich nur etwa eineinhalb
megajoule energie pro kilogramm
zugegeben elektromotoren sind
wahrscheinlich etwa doppelt so effizient
wie verbrennungsmotoren
es ist aber immer noch nur ein bruchteil
dessen was wir mit benzin erreichen
können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als norwegen verkündet innerhalb von 20
jahren kurzstreckenflüge nur noch mit
elektro flugzeugen zu erlauben ist das
ein schock für die luftfahrtbranche
eine neue generation von luftfahrt
technikern aber stellt sich der
herausforderung
sie wollen eine grüne revolution starten
noch vor wenigen jahren hätten die
meisten sie für undenkbar gehalten
[Musik]
die geschichte begann in einer garage
ich zog zurück ins haus meiner eltern
und fing an flugzeugteile zu entwerfen
und zu bauen
thomas betrifft ist kein typischer
flugzeugkonstrukteur
eigentlich wollte er produktdesigner
werden doch als er für seinen
uni-abschluss nach einer fall studie
sucht ändern sich seine pläne
ich fragte mich ob es nicht interessant
wäre die prozesse des industriedesigns
für die entwicklung neuartiger flugzeuge
zu nutzen
[Musik]
also die nicht genauso daran wie wenn
man ein fahrrad oder einen kaffeebecher
entwirft der prozess ist mehr oder
weniger derselbe mann analysiert wie die
menschen die produkte benutzen wie sie
mit ihnen interagieren
[Musik]
eine erkenntnis die art und weise wie
menschen reisen wollen verändert sich
gerade dramatisch
in norwegen haben wir bereits 30 40
prozent elektroautos als ich das erste
mal ein elektroauto fuhr hatte ich das
gefühl das ist definitiv die zukunft
sauber wenn du danach in einem
verbrenner den gang einlegt diese
explosionen im motor hörst und quasi die
hitze spürst wird dir sofort klar das
kann es nicht sein
[Musik]
in norwegens bilder und unwegsame natur
war das reisen immer schon schön aber
schwierig
pro trifft kommt auf die idee für die
elektro fliegerei einen speziellen
aspekt der landschaft auszunutzen das
wasser
[Musik]
insbesondere norwegens 450.000 sehen und
fjorde
mich faszinierte der gedanke eine art
fliegendes boot zu bauen das so
effizient ist wie ein herkömmliches
flugzeug
die elektrische technologie macht das
erst möglich wir müssen ja keinen großen
schweren verbrennungsmotor mehr einbauen
die kraft kommt aus dem leichten
elektromotor das eröffnet uns
möglichkeiten die die konstrukteure
während der vergangenen 100 jahre nicht
ab
man kann plötzlich ganz andere flugzeuge
bauen
[Musik]
von anfang an wird betrifft von einer
kleinen gruppe talentierter
gleichgesinnter unterstützt
hier erreicht die arbeit von über einem
jahrzehnt ihren vorläufigen höhepunkt
der erste testflug steht an
die neuartige maschine soll zum vorbild
für eine neue generation von
wasserflugzeugen werden
doch bevor es im wasser landen kann muss
es zunächst abheben zum aller ersten mal
t en suite wir haben mit zwei drei
leuten dieses flugzeug entwickelt keiner
von uns hat so was schon mal gemacht
jedes einzelne teil haben wir selbst von
hand gebaut
natürlich haben wir alles genau
überprüfen wie aber irgendwann muss
jemand damit vom boden abheben und
dieser jemand muss auch dann einen
kühlen kopf bewahren wenn die sache
richtig schief geht dafür brauchen sie
einen profi sonst kann das flugzeug
abstürzen wenn nur eine kleinigkeit
nicht stimmt und die wahrscheinlichkeit
dafür ist bei einem konzept wie diesem
ziemlich hoch
und das ist der profi
-skandal norwegens erfahrenster
testpilot ein mann der vom weltkriegs
jäger bis zur neuesten f-35 leiten alles
geflogen hat
das ist alles reine theorie bis das
flugzeug tatsächlich abheben alles steht
bloß auf dem papier die aerodynamik
sagen ja das ist stabil aber man weiß es
nicht bis es fliegt ich war so extrem
angespannt dass alles irgendwie
verschwimmt ich weiß kaum noch was genau
vor den testflug passiert ist
märz
[Musik]
die mainzer wasserflugzeuge sind nichts
neues es gibt sie seit den anfängen der
luft vor
und wenn sie zb von oslo nach hamburg
fliegen finden sie eigentlich auf einen
fluss landen das ist heute aber wegen
des lärms den der verbrennungsmotor und
der propeller vor allem beim start
verursacht nicht erlaubt die deswegen
gibt es keinen flugverkehr in ihn
stecken die elektrische technologie ist
natürlich um viele dezibel leiser
ungefähr um die 50 prozent damit sind
sie in etwa auf dem level eines normalen
boot
es gibt also eigentlich keinen grund
mehr flugzeuge aus den städten zu
verbannen
das ist eine große veränderung die uns
bevorsteht leise grüne produkte kommen
in die städte
[Musik]
das war eine riesige erleichterung
fast wie im traum
[Musik]
bei uns der emotional
münchen
niemand besonders als es kiel aus dem
flugzeug kletterten
ich nahm ihn in die arme und wusste weiß
ich
meine sonst nie
du kommst du das ergebnis von 78 jahren
harter arbeit so ein testpilot hat ein
erstaunlich feines gespür für technik
die in lemberg sofort was funktioniert
und was nicht
[Musik]
ich denke bei jedem neuartigen prototyp
der noch nie zuvor geflogen ist gibt es
am ende eine liste mit dingen die man
noch ändern oder verbessern
[Musik]
für brot reis rift und sein team bei
ebay kraft folgen jetzt tests auf dem
wasser
parallel dazu werden die bisherigen
ergebnisse ausgewertet
ziel ist ein modell mit vier sitzen
einer flugdauer von zwei stunden und
einer reichweite von 500 kilometern
produktionsbeginn soll in zwei jahren
sein und das ist noch nicht alles die
große frage ist wer übernimmt die
verantwortung für den ausbau der
flughafen und hafen infrastruktur
kümmert sich darum dass die leute ihre
elektro flugzeuge aufladen können wir
entwickeln das produkt aber das alles
muss parallel dazu passieren sonst ist
das ganze projekt sinnlos
wir brauchen ein universelles system das
wir alle ganz einfach benutzen können
worum geht es dabei um stromspannung um
die art des stroms um ladezeiten und
ganz simpel welche form hat der stecker
und passte in den anschluss eines
flugzeugs
in schweden und norwegen stehen diese
fragen auf der tagesordnung
gemeinsam haben sie eine internationale
test arena für die luftfahrt der zukunft
ins leben gerufen den green fly away ein
großes areal mit zwei internationalen
flughäfen
hier können designer ingenieure und
luftfahrtunternehmen neue ideen
entwickeln und testen das projekt ist
ein deutliches signal und es zieht
luftfahrtpioniere aus aller welt an
ich vertrete pro flight eine firma aus
tschechien
wir haben dieses flugzeug entwickelt es
ist voll elektrisch mit einer 35
kilowattstunden batterie und kann über
drei stunden fliegen
winterliche bedingungen sind nur eine
der vielen herausforderungen denen die
neuen maschinen gewachsen sein müssen um
regulierungsbehörden und zukünftige
betreiber zu überzeugen
green fly away ist auch für
flughafenbetreiber wichtig denn hier
können sie sehen welche infrastruktur in
zukunft nötig sein wird
[Musik]
wenn die elektrische luftfahrt auf dem
massenmarkt fuß fassen soll wird es
allerdings größere flugzeuge geben
müssen
inspiriert durch norwegens strenge
vorgaben haben anders force land und
seine partnerin klare andreasson ein
konzept entwickelt
das ist die hts ninety nine 19 70 es
rein elektrisches flugzeug mit 400
kilometern reichweite
wir wollen dieses flugzeug bis 2026 für
den kommerziellen einsatz zertifizieren
lassen
ein großer moment für das start-up
vossloh und präsentiert den
einflussreichsten playern der branche
seine vision
auch mitglieder der schwedischen
königsfamilie sind da
das ist kein forschungsprojekt wir
wollen auf den kommerziellen markt
noch gibt es keinen flugzeug prototyp
aber immerhin der elektrische antrieb
funktioniert
oder zumindest so gut wie
[Musik]
wir hatten den einen oder anderen
rückschlag aber wir kennen jetzt die
ursachen und haben wieder einmal gelernt
wie sorgfältig man sowas konstruieren
muss
jetzt ist das problem gelöst und es kann
losgehen
für fonds land und sein team kommt es
jetzt darauf an dass die motoren tests
erfolgreich verlaufen
nur dann können sie im zeitplan bleiben
in einer branche in der neuentwicklungen
normalerweise viel zeit brauchen hat das
unternehmen schon eine menge erreicht
[Musik]
alles begann anfang 2018 damals
arbeitete ich als wissenschaftler an der
universität in göteborg und war gerade
von einem austausch haiti zurückgekommen
ich war sicher dass der elektrifizierung
die zukunft gehört wenn wir dabei sein
wollten mussten wir ein unternehmen
gründen kaum technologie war schon da
forsters verlobte klarer teilt seine
leidenschaft
das nötige startkapital kommt von drei
kombinierte einem amerikanischen
investitionsprogramm das schon vielen
unternehmen auf die beine geholfen hat
ich habe meinen job gekündigt klarer
auch
am anfang hatte ich gemischte gefühle
ich hatte einen guten job ein sicheres
einkommen und alles
aber wir wussten beide wie viel zeit und
energie das ganze kosten würde
entweder wir machen das zusammen oder
werden gar keine gemeinsame zeit mehr
damals waren wir zu zweit und wir
wollten ein luftfahrtunternehmen
aufbauen um sowas zu machen musst du ein
bisschen verrückt sein
aber wenn du verrückt genug bis zu
glauben dass du das schaffen kannst ist
schon die hälfte erreicht
im sommer 2020 hat das unternehmen einen
hangar büros ein engagiertes team mit
zwölf mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
und ein konzept das allmählich gestalt
annimmt
[Musik]
ich führe sie ein wenig herum
unser vorbild sind die startups aus der
software industrie sie brauchen ein
kleines team mit hochtalentierten
ingenieuren die sich voll einbringen und
auf der höhe der zeit sind
wenn sie die richtige mischung
hinkriegen können sie alles schaffen
das hier ist nigel
sein lebenslauf liest sich fast wie eine
moderne geschichte der luftfahrt
michael piepers offizieller titel lautet
technikvorstand seiner kolleginnen und
kollegen von denen manche zum ersten mal
überhaupt ein flugzeug bauen nennen ihn
liebevoll kann
wir haben einige der besten leute der
ganzen luftfahrtbranche ich stehe jeden
tag mit ihnen arbeiten zu dürfen
[Musik]
sollen wir noch mal zurück an den
zeichentisch oder ist es besser das
einfach auszuprobieren
[Musik]
dann kämen zum beispiel benjamin
er ist nicht von dieser welt
es gibt da diese elektronische
motorsteuerung eine software mit der man
die steuerung von motoren programmiert
dafür hatte einen globalen standard
geschaffen in seinem keller
seine software hat ihren weg in ich
glaube 200.000 verschiedene maschinen
gefunden
alles von elektro skateboards bis hin zu
motorrädern
momentan arbeitet er unter anderem an
eine art elektrischem herzen das witzig
ist weil unsere firma so heißt
was sich an dieser ganzen elektrischen
revolution so toll finde ist dass es
eigentlich ein 150 jahre altes gebiet
der physik ist stellen sie sich ein paar
elektromagneten in einem ring vor und
eine stange in der mitte wir schalten
die elektromagneten der reihe nach ein
und aus das bringt ein stück metall dazu
zwischen verschiedenen positionen hin
und her zu springen
wir schalten die magnete sehr schnell
aber behutsam ein und aus also das muss
ganz sanft von einem zum anderen geben
sonst rappelt brummt und klappert das
ding
was hat das alles möglich gemacht
der durchbruch kam in den 1980 er jahren
mit den erschwinglichen computern der
bewegliche teil ist nichts anderes als
ein klumpen eisen in der mitte aber was
schafft er erzeugt eine unglaubliche
kraft etwas was ein herkömmlicher
elektromotor nicht kann
wir sind nur ein kleines startup aber
wir können einen motor entwickeln der so
leistungsstark ist wie ein
düsentriebwerk aber mit dem dreifachen
wirkungsgrad und das internet monaten
für einen ingenieur ist das fast zu
schön um wahr zu sein wirklich
fantastisch
was die da machen ist das zeitgemäße
äquivalent des machine bauingenieurs der
einen verbrennungsmotor tuned um den
perfekten sound und die optimale
leistung herauszuholen
aber diese jungs arbeiten mit software
die elektronik und software für dieses
rick hier habe ich größtenteils selbst
entwickelt und geschrieben um zu
garantieren dass so ein system wirklich
sicher ist muss man es im grunde selbst
gebaut haben denn nur dann kann es
wirklich verstehen
die nötige zertifizierung ist auch der
grund für die entscheidung genau 19
sitze für passagiere einzubauen
sie steht für die pragmatische
herangehensweise des jungen unternehmens
das alles einem ziel unterordnet eine
große elektrische passagiermaschine so
schnell wie möglich in die luft zu
bekommen
in diesem jahr wurde das erste
elektroflugzeug zertifiziert die
pipistrellus elektro ein zweisitzer das
ist die zertifizierungs basis
die zertifizierung bestätigt die
luftdichtigkeit einer bestimmten
kategorie von flugzeugen sie ist für
serienproduktion und kommerziellen
betrieb zwingend erforderlich
zertifizierungs basis erlaubt bis zu 19
passagiere diesen rahmen können wir
jetzt für unser flugzeug nutzen
das ermöglicht unseren sehr
ambitionierten zeitplan erst
hätten wir 20 sitze oder mehr wäre dass
die gleiche zertifizierungs basis wie
bei einem symbol jet
was sie machen ist vernünftig sie nutzen
eine gelegenheit die sich ihnen bietet
sie müssen das flugzeug nicht komplett
neu erfinden sondern nur das
antriebssystem anpassen
doch wenn die vision einer schönen neuen
luftfahrt welt wirklichkeit werden soll
müssen forssell und und sein team
beweisen dass motor und batterie der
aufgabe gewachsen sind wie testet man
das möglichst einfach und realistisch
mit einer reihe von halogen birnen
[Musik]
beim start ziehst du am meisten energie
walde steigen musste aber wenn die
reiseflughöhe schließlich erreicht ist
und du nicht mehr steigst brauchst du
weniger leistung
die lampen leuchten jetzt weniger hell
weil wir weniger energie ziehen um die
höhe nur zu halten
soweit wir das bisher beurteilen können
werden die batterien sehr lange halten
und das stimmt mich wirklich positiv was
die ganze sache angeht
die theorie ist das eine aber wird
benjamin väter software auch in der
praxis funktionieren
[Musik]
fekter wir haben das batterie modell an
den multi controller angeschlossen das
bringt jetzt ungefähr die 10 fache
leistung im vergleich zu vorher alle
batterien sind in reihe an die sicherung
und den hauptschalter angeschlossen und
denen werde ich jetzt einschalten
bitte senden sie das nicht falls das
ding uns gleich ab braucht
ich fange mit geringer leistung aber
voller spannung an und guck mal wie das
funktioniert
jetzt sieht es gut aus
ich gebe mal ein bisschen mehr saft und
guck wo die grenze ist
ein extrem wichtiger test
der motor ist das herzstück des gesamten
projekts
was war das das kann nicht so gut
denn die sicherung durchbrennt haben wir
wahrscheinlich ein problem weil das eine
riesige induktive spitze bedeutet aber
das risiko gehe ich ein kommt dann
hoffentlich bin ich nicht zu übermütig
mit 70 ampere sollten wir auf der
sicheren seite sein was die sicherung
angeht
wollen
[Musik]
das ist ein bisschen mehr wind
das projekt es 19 hat gerade einen
großen schritt nach vorne gemacht
[Applaus]
und jetzt die leistung nochmal
verzehnfachen
das ist der nächste schritt
die entwicklung neuer technologien ist
weniger eine frage der zeit
es geht eher darum dass ingenieure die
technologie bis an ihre grenzen treiben
manchmal findest du aus dass es noch
einen extra gibt
[Musik]
vielleicht dachtest du hättest längst
alles gegeben aber
dann in texte diesen zusätzlichen gang
und schaltet plötzlich den turbo an und
erreicht viel mehr als du je für möglich
gehalten
[Musik]
sie wollen nicht noch ein paar jahre auf
ein neu entwickeltes elektroflugzeug
warten
als die kanadische dj tobi war im sommer
1947 zum ersten mal abhebt an kaum
jemand dass über 70 jahre später genau
dieses flugzeug eine neue ära in der
geschichte der luftfahrt einläuten wird
wir behalten ein fach das flugzeug das
wir kennen und lieben das alles macht
was es soll bis auf den motor
es kann durchaus sinnvoll seines auf
elektroantrieb umzurüsten wir
ermöglichen unseren kunden den umstieg
genau das hat habe er in vancouver mit
ihrem ikonischen wasserflugzeug gemacht
mit einem simplen austausch des motors
ist es allerdings nicht getan
wenn sie den großen schweren sternmotor
der biber durch einen kleinen leichten
elektromotor ersetzen müssen sie den
motor weiter nach vorne verlegen um den
schwerpunkt des flugzeugs beizubehalten
dafür haben wir die nase der biber
verlängert und sie gleichzeitig aero
dynamischer gemacht
[Musik]
im dezember 2009 10 wird der 750 ps
elektromotor getestet
[Musik]
unter den augen der weltpresse startet
das erste vollelektrische
verkehrsflugzeug der geschichte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch ohne den elektrischen aspekt wurde
das flugzeug nero dynamischer hinsicht
effizienter sowie das gleiche flugzeug
braucht jetzt weniger energie
das ist an sich schon eine wichtige
erkenntnis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach dem erfolg mit der fünfsitzigen
beaver wendet sich max der größeren 970
in chester caravan zu
ein robustes arbeitspferd dass auf der
ganzen welt eingesetzt wird
wenn du etwas anderes verwendest als
geplant dann hat das vor und nachteile
[Musik]
mit dem normalen verbrennungsmotor hat
sie eine reichweite von über 1500 km
das ist phänomenal
in wirklichkeit fliegt aber niemand 1500
km mit einer carroll war sie hat nicht
mal eine toilette und keine druckkabine
aber es ging die elektrische version mit
den heutigen batterien schafft nur um
die 200 kilometern
aber zugleich sind die kosten enorm
gesunken die stromkosten für einen
anderthalb stündigen flug betragen 24
dollar
für die gleichen eineinhalb stunden
kostet der treibstoff für den
verbrennungsmotor 404 dollar
404 dollar im vergleich zu 24 dollar und
das ist nur der treibstoff
das umrüsten solcher älteren maschinen
ist trotzdem wohl eher ein nischenthema
tatsächlich geht es aber um sehr viel
mehr
wenn sie vor ein oder zwei jahren zu
einem batteriehersteller gegangen wären
und gesagt hätten warum entwickelt er
nicht eine stromquelle für eine
elektroflugzeug wäre die antwort gewesen
welches elektroflugzeug
wären sie zu einem flugzeughersteller
gegangen und hätten gesagt hey warum
entwickelt ihr nicht ein elektrisches
flugzeug wäre die antwort gewesen mit
welchem antrieb system
jetzt gibt es ein antriebssystem das
leistungsfähig leicht an zuverlässig
genug ist um ein flugzeug anzutreiben
jetzt entwickelt dafür flugzeuge
[Musik]
genau das beschloss ein israelischer
physiker zu tun doch dafür brauchte er
eine firma also gründete er sie
[Musik]
am anfang fragten uns die leute ob wir
das tesla der lüfte werden wollten und
wir sagen nein das ist der falsche
vergleich wir wollen das modell t der
luftfahrt bauen
wir wollen das flugzeug bauen das
normale menschen mit normalem einkommen
für ihre normalen wege nutzen können das
ist etwas ganz anderes nicht bloß für
den urlaub die geschäftsreise oder dem
besuch bei der tante wir reden vom
täglichen pendeln neu erfunden
einen traum zu haben ist eine sache die
frage aber ist wird ihn jemand teilen
für die kunden muss sich das ganze in
ökonomischer hinsicht lohnen man kann
nicht einfach sagen okay macht euch
keine sorgen ich werde ein flugzeug
bauen dass wir ein auto funktioniert und
bringe da wird das kaufen das macht euch
keine sorgen wird der luftfahrtindustrie
natürlich nicht genügen
zielgruppe sind die betreiber kleinerer
regionalfluglinie
am ende der recherchen stellt sich
heraus dass neun die magische zahl ist
um den markt zu erobern bedarf es einer
ganz besonderen strategie
die aviation alles ist ein 970 flugzeug
92 also mit platz für zwei piloten oder
besatzungsmitglieder
die aviation alles hat eine reichweite
von knapp 900 kilometern und eine
reisegeschwindigkeit von fast 500
kilometern pro stunde
dank ihres elektromotors sind die
betriebskosten extrem niedrig diese
aussichten überzeugten eine ganze reihe
von kunden vorbestellungen zu machen für
das unternehmen wird es ernst
[Musik]
eine unserer ersten investitionen war
ein obszön großer supercomputer
den nutzen wir für simulationen
aber man kann soviel simulieren wie man
will am ende muss man es tatsächlich
bauen und sehen ob es funktioniert
wie viele flugzeuge haben wir vor der
ewe schon alles gebaut die einfache
antwort ist 0
niemand hier hat je ein flugzeug gebaut
[Musik]
ich will das jetzt nicht unbedingt als
frischen ansatz bezeichnen aber
natürlich hat es vorteile wenn man
enthusiastisch und unbedarft an so ein
projekt herangeht und bei null anfängt
aber ganz ehrlich um dieser branche
lernt man bescheidenheit und es gibt
auch sonst einiges zu lernen
[Musik]
mario high und sein team nehmen kontakt
mit mehr als 100 erfahrenen
subunternehmern in mehr als 20 ländern
auf
wir mussten durch den reifen springen
und sie davon überzeugen dass unser
projekt vierten aufwand und risiko
rechtfertigt damit sie mitmachen
[Musik]
es sind große namen der bronx dabei und
auch kleine firmen
[Musik]
es gibt bei uns diesen witz wie bauen 50
leute im flugzeug die antwort lautet
gemeinsam man braucht leute die mit
anderen zusammenarbeiten die die
entsprechende expertise atmen
wir haben zwar das konzept entworfen
aber das heißt nicht dass wir auch die
besten leute sind um bestimmte teile
herzustellen oder die flügel zu bauen
ein unternehmen lässt sich nicht lange
bitten
wenn sie etwas von grund auf neu
konstruieren und mehrere elektromotoren
einsetzen die sie an den günstigsten
stellen anbringen können weil sie klein
und leicht sind werden erstaunliche
dinge möglich
drei motoren zwei davon an den
flügelspitzen
das erhöht die effizienz des flugzeugs
auf verschiedene weise
zum beispiel
bei flugzeugen sieht man manchmal diese
rauch wirbel an den flügelspitzen
[Musik]
sie sehen vielleicht cool aus sind aber
eigentlich schlecht
sie erzeugen nämlich enormen
luftwiderstand und bremsen das flugzeug
ab es braucht also mehr energie um
voranzukommen
was passiert wenn sie an den
flügelspitzen propeller anbringen die
sich genau entgegengesetzt zu den
wirbeln drehen dann verschwinden die
wird
das flugzeug gleitet sanft durch die
luft hat weniger widerstand und braucht
weniger energie
mit propellern an den flügelspitzen
lässt sich das flugzeug auch besser
steuern
wenn bei einer landung mit starkem
seitenwind die triebwerke nahe am rumpf
sitzen oder ein einzelner propeller in
der mitte auf der nase sitzt dann
steuert der pilot die landebahn nicht
direkt an sondern in einem winkel
man sieht dass gut in videos von
seitenwind landung
das flugzeug fliegt stark versetzt zur
landebahn an und man denkt wie soll das
ding denn landen und dann in
allerletzter sekunde zieht der pilot des
rum und landet stellen sie sich vor sie
könnten die beiden flügelspitzen motoren
unabhängig voneinander steuern dann
können sie als pilot die landebahn auch
bei seitenwind einfach gerade an steuern
wie sonst auch es werden manöver möglich
die früher aus physikalischen gründen
nicht funktioniert hätten
2009/10 sorgt die maschine bei der
pariser luftfahrtschau für aufsehen
obwohl sie potenziell flugtauglich ist
wird sie zunächst intensiv am boden
getestet
ja
ja es ist ein flugzeug und es könnte
fliegen aber was würde uns das jetzt
bringen es gibt eine menge prototypen
geflogen sind sie hatten ihren
jungfernflug und das was sie haben
bewiesen dass sie funktionieren
vielleicht haben sie sogar einen rekord
gebrochen sind besonders hoch oder
besonders weit geflogen großartig aber
das ist nicht unser ziel wir sind ein
unternehmen das ein produkt herstellt
und das muss sicher und zertifizierer
sein und es muss in serie zu einem preis
hergestellt werden können der
konkurrenzfähig ist das ist der druck
und druck bedeutet manchmal auch risiko
anfang 2020 nur wenige wochen nach dem
sensationellen debüt in paris gerät die
aviation alles erneut in die
schlagzeilen
während der bodentests verursachen
batterien einen elektrischen brand und
zwar sind es batterien die zur boden
ausrüstung gehören aber es kommen
trotzdem fragen auf fragen nach der
sicherheit von batteriebetriebenen
flugzeugen
[Musik]
wenn sie sich wegen der batterien sorgen
machen möchte ich sie beruhigen
stellen sie sich vor jemand führt ihnen
zum ersten mal überhaupt ein
düsentriebwerk vor
der freak oder jemand will sie überreden
in ein flugzeug zu steigen das 100
tonnen kerosin an bord hat und
er erklärt ihnen dass das kerosin gleich
da unter dem flügel neben ihnen im trink
wert verbrannt wird
[Musik]
vielleicht haben sie angst vor dem feuer
mir geht es dagegen nur um die frage ob
wir das feuer im notfall in schach
halten können das feuer ist ein beleg
dafür dass wir die technologie
vorantreiben und grenzen ausloten
ingenieure haben den schaden damit der
kunde ihn nicht
ein guter freund sagte mir mal oma wenn
du ein flugzeug entwickelt und am ende
des tages sind alle deine leute in
sicherheit drei räder sind am boden und
das flugzeug steht noch dann war das ein
guter tag
unsere tests sind teil des
entwicklungsprozesses
ohne sie hätte man am ende kein
zuverlässiges produkt
[Musik]
in folge des brandes wird eine
zusätzliche sicherung ebene eingebaut
das battery system wird auf 16
feuersichere kammern verteilt jede davon
liefert genug energie um das flugzeug
notfalls alleine versorgen zu können
falls doch was passiert und das müssen
wir verhindern sind maschine und
passagiere trotzdem sicher vielleicht
kommen sie nicht ans ursprüngliche ziel
aber der grundgedanke der luftfahrt ist
nicht pannen zu verhindern sondern auch
bei einer panne die sicherheit zu
gewährleisten
und genau da kommen wir mit unseren
batterien gerade hin
flugtests stehen unmittelbar bevor bei
einem geschätzten preis von 8 millionen
dollar cash john rege nachfrage nach der
invasion alles das unternehmen plant
ehrgeizige stückzahlen
[Musik]
ein paar hundert pro jahr einige tausend
innerhalb der ersten zehn jahre sind ein
realistischer ansatz
noch stieg das geschäft mit elektro
flugzeugen in den kinderschuhen
doch eines ist klar sobald sich die
batterie technologie verbessert wird es
rapide wachsen
[Musik]
und unsere ersten biber hatten batterien
mit einer leistung von etwa 145
wattstunden pro kilo
heute gibt es batterien mit 400
wattstunden pro kilo mann
dazwischen liegen nur zwölf monate
da sind zum einen die chemiker ist sie
forschen einen neuen chemikalien mit dem
wir mehr energie in den kasten speichern
können dann gibt es systemingenieure wie
mich die daran arbeiten die batterien
effizienter betreiben zu können sie zu
hegen und zu pflegen wenn man zu werden
außerdem können elektro ingenieure die
zellen in verschiedenen konfigurationen
anordnen und fliegen wir sie
hintereinander oder lieber nebeneinander
diese schöne neue welt bietet uns viele
möglichkeiten
[Musik]
der britische flughafen krenn viert
beschreibt sich selbst als ganz normaler
lizensierter flugplatz mit
ungewöhnlicher forschungstätigkeit
heute steht nur ein boden test auf dem
programm aber dieses flugzeug betrieben
von zero ist das weltweit erste
kommerzielle flugzeug das mit einer
wasserstoff brennstoffzelle geflogen ist
in einer brennstoffzelle reagieren
wasserstoff und sauerstoff miteinander
dabei wird chemische in elektrische
energie umgewandelt
diese energie treibt dann den
elektromotor an
silvias jungfernflug mit dieser technik
ist ein bahnbrechender moment
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei der umwandlung der chemischen
energie des wasserstoffs in nutzbare
elektrische energie verbindet sich
wasserstoff h2 mit sauerstoff aus der
luft
22 wasser wasser ist das einzige
abfallprodukt das bei einem hydro
elektrischen system wie dem unseren
entsteht das wasser kann man während des
fluges ab lassen es entstehen keine
schädlichen emissionen und es hat keine
auswirkungen auf das klima
[Musik]
der erste flug dauert nur 15 minuten
jetzt werden die systeme für einen
längeren flug getestet rund 400
kilometer in etwa zwei stunden sind
geplant
dollar für den kommerziellen betrieb
brauchen wir natürlich die entsprechende
infrastruktur
arbeiten am flughafen wasserstoff aus
erneuerbaren strom emissionsfrei
produzieren dort lagern und jedes
geeignete flugzeug damit betanken
[Musik]
hier links in den kanistern ist ganz
normales wasser das wasser wird in den
elektrolyseur hier im container
umgewandelt ein elektrolyseur spaltet
das wasser mit elektrischem strom in
sauerstoff und wasserstoff
der strom kann natürlich grün sein also
emissionsfrei sonne oder wind
so produziert man grünen wasserstoff es
reicht nicht aus den wasserstoff zu
lagern man muss ihnen auch tanken können
es geht mit einem ganz normalen
betankung system sie schließen diesen
stecker an das flugzeug an und drücken
den startknopf
das system betankt das flugzeug und wenn
es voll ist kann es vier bis fünfhundert
kilometer weit fliegen
[Musik]
diese nachgerüstete piper mit sechs
sitzen dient ausschließlich als
fliegendes labor
für den kommerziellen betrieb muss das
siegerteam in größeren dimensionen
denken
[Musik]
die energiedichte von wasserstoff pro
kilo treibstoff ist dreimal so hoch wie
die von flugzeugtreibstoff das ist
wirklich spannend
und das könnte entscheidend sein das
maximale abfluggewicht eines airbus a380
liegt bei 565 tonnen
vollgetankt wiegt allein der treibstoff
2 154 tonnen das sind 45 prozent des
gesamtgewichts
und ein geringeres staat gewicht
bedeutet automatisch einen geringeren
energiebedarf
bei einem flugzeug kommt es letztlich
aufs gewicht
ab einer gewissen größe kann man es
nicht mehr mit batterien fliegen weil es
zu schwer wird dann muss man auf
wasserstoff umsteigen
unsere vision ist es ein skalierbares
system zu entwickeln
die ersten kommerziellen flüge sind
schon für 2023 geplant das system soll
im prinzip von kleineren maschinen bis
zu schmal um flugzeugen wie dem airbus
a320 funktionieren der ab 2030 in den
focus konnte
[Musik]
alle hier im team arbeiten für das selbe
ziel für einen nachhaltigen luftverkehr
[Musik]
50 prozent der weltweiten flugreisen
sind kurzstrecken unter 1000 kilometern
auf diesen markt ziehen wir mit dem
hydro elektrischen antrieb ab
das ist ein großartiges ziel 50 prozent
der heutigen kohlenstoff emissionen
durch flüge einzusparen
[Musik]
sieht aus wie ein albernes kleines
spielzeug aber
es hat alle systeme die eine neue ära
der elektrischen luftfahrt prägen werden
[Musik]
marina bay singapur ein
team der deutschen firma volo copter bei
den letzten vorbereitungen
[Musik]
dieses fluggerät soll einen
bahnbrechenden flug absolvieren und
schließlich die nutzung des urbanen
luftraums revolutionieren
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt im jahr 2011
damals werden alexander zuse und sein
freund software designer stefan wolf
ungewollt zur internet sensation
ich sah so eine kleine ferngesteuerte
drohne
und weil ich so ein technikfreak bin
fragte ich mich wie könnte man so ein
ding so vergrößern dass ein mensch damit
fliegen kann
das ist der erste bemannte flug eines
senkrecht staaten denn von
elektromotoren angetriebenen fluggerät
das besondere features der sitz ball
wir brauchten eine sehr leichte lösung
und es stellte sich heraus dass diese
sitz bälle für ein paar 400 kilogramm
zugelassen sind wenn mich heute jemand
fragt wo low coster was ist das sage ich
wir haben dieses ding mit dem sitzball
gebaut ich weiß der sitz ball die
geschichte
[Musik]
eigentlich wollten wir bloß beweisen
dass es funktioniert
richten wir damit großes aufsehen in der
öffentlichkeit und bei luftfahrtexperten
sagte
wenn leute das ist fantastisch wir
denken seit jahrzehnten über dezentrale
elektrische antriebe nach und ihr habt
gezeigt dass es geht
damit eröffnen sich in sachen
luftfahrtsicherheit ganz neue
möglichkeiten
[Musik]
angespornt durch das interesse sichern
sich wolf und reuter eine finanzierung
und entwickeln das konzept professionell
weiter
hielt es für absolut klar dass ich auf
der ganzen welt leute darauf stürzen
würden aber lange zeit gab es gar keine
konkurrenz wir waren die einzigen
wir haben kaum junge unternehmen sind
wie junge menschen sie bewirken solche
wunder weil sie sich nicht ablenken
lassen von leuten die sagen irgendwas
sei unmöglich
am anfang dachten uns die leute bis die
eigentlich welche probleme auf euch
warten und wir sagten zum glück haben
wir keine ahnung
im rückblick sagen sie jetzt dass es
leute von außen gebraucht hat
dass ein luftfahrt insider hätte das
alles niemals angefangen er hätte nur
unüberwindbare herausforderungen und
probleme gesehen
wir wollen uns diesen spirit so lange
wie möglich bewahren er hat möglich
gemacht was lange für unmöglich gehalten
wurde
wir wollten die pioniere sein aber wie
sich zeigte sind wir welche
es ging los mit zehn mitarbeitern
heute sind es hunderte um die
zertifizierung zu bekommen muss
buchstäblich jedes bauteil neu entworfen
sicherer und zuverlässiger gemacht
werden
damit auch bei einer panne nicht schief
geht
wir haben redundanzen in all unseren
kritischen komponenten am deutlichsten
sichtbar in elektrische
antriebseinheiten von den 18 propellern
können einige ausfallen und trotzdem
können wir den flug sicher beenden das
ist etwas völlig neues bei herkömmlichen
hubschraubern gibt es eine sehr komplexe
anordnung von komponenten mechaniken und
bauteilen aber wenn nur eines dieser
elemente ausfällt kommt das ganze system
in schwierigkeiten beim polo copter ist
das ganz anders dank unserer
sicherheitsarchitektur können wir
luftfahrzeuge bauen die es früher nicht
gab und die viel viel sicherer sind
der volo copter ist nicht nur sicherer
sondern auch leiser die einwände die
bisher gegen hubschrauber im städtischen
luftraum sprechen könnten also
ausgeräumt werden
deshalb ist der testflug in singapur so
wichtig die freigabe dafür ist für volo
copter so etwas wie der nächste schritt
in die zukunft
duncan walker von der britischen firma
skype hat dafür etwas geschaffen das
sich am ehesten als temporärer popup
flughafen beschreiben lässt ein wärter
port
[Musik]
er behandelte hunderte von menschen
warteten im wörterbuch und in strömen es
schüttete wie aus eimern
motto happy wir hatten pech mit dem
wetter wir wussten nicht ob das ganze
überhaupt stattfinden konnte
herr punkt es ist ein militärischer
luftraum da bekommt man ein klar
definiertes stadtfenster man kann nicht
einfach so von 13 auf 14 uhr
verschiedene junge entweder du startest
pünktlich oder gar nicht tätig krise
alle waren da die presse das fernsehen
denn da wurden durchschnitten und in
letzter minute riss der himmel auf
[Musik]
alles hat perfekt funktioniert
aber ich glaube den wenigsten war klar
wie knapp das war
für mich war es ein ganz besonderer tag
ist doch klar
wir bekamen tolles feedback von den
aufsichtsbehörden und von der verwaltung
vor allem aber aus der öffentlichkeit
zum ersten mal konnte man es sehen und
hören oder noch wichtiger ist nicht
hören sie drehten sich nicht mal um weil
sie gar nichts mitkriegen wir konnten
eine menge mitnehmen und auf andere
städte in der ganzen welt übertragen
es soll kein spielzeug für reiche leute
werden wie die heutigen hubschrauber
es soll eine professionell betriebene
flotte werden die der öffentlichkeit zur
verfügung steht also den besuchern und
bewohnern einer stadt
so können wir den zugang zu dieser neuen
technologie demokratisieren
wir können diesen service zu einem preis
knapp über einer heutigen taxifahrt
anbieten
so wird er einen breiten publikum
zugänglich
das ist nur der erste teil eines
ambitionierten plans anfangs werden die
kopf davon piloten gesteuert in zukunft
aber sollen sie autonom sein selbst
fliegen aber wie genau soll das gehen
woods automatisch bedeutet wir drücken
einen knopf das flugzeug fliegt von a
nach b und alles ist gut solange kein
ballon den weg ist woods autonom
bedeutet die maschine entscheidet
selbstständig um den ballon herum zu
fliegen die technologien star schon
heute
der coppa kann zum beispiel automatisch
not landeplätze entlang der strecke
erkennen und auch ob die preise
er erkennt auch flügel und andere
fluggeräte wie kleine drohnen schon so
früh dass er rechtzeitig gegenmaßnahmen
einleitet und dem hindernis auszuweichen
oder einen zusammenstoß zu vermeiden so
weit ist die technologie heute schon
zusammen mit einer reihe von partnern
forschungseinrichtungen kommerziellen
unternehmen forschen wir weiter daran
es gibt verschiedene herausforderungen
für die urbane mobilität
ich teile sie in drei bereichen
regulierung technologie und
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz mit genug
geld und clips lassen sich die
technologischen herausforderungen immer
lösen die regulierung ist auf dem
richtigen weg das timing ist weniger
leicht zu beeinflussen als die
technologie aber es gibt dank
wirtschaftlicher und technologischer
impulse eine gewisse dynamik die große
unbekannte ist die gesellschaftliche
akzeptanz wie werden die menschen das
neue system als transportmittel annehmen
werden sie es lieben weil es zeit spart
und probleme löst oder ist es eher
ungewohnt und macht den leuten angst
dann dauert es länger bis es sich
wirklich verbreitet
unbemannte drohnen könnten beim übergang
helfen
im auftrag der britischen
gesundheitsbehörde
beliefern danken walk on sein team
bereits testweise abgelegene schottische
inseln patrone mit medikamenten
[Musik]
das ist wirklich super als kurve zum
schluss kam noch mal zusätzlich schwung
in die sache aus routine flügen wurden
wichtige lieferungen wir brachten kurve
testkits von der westküste schottlands
zur isle of man in abgelegenen gebieten
wo straßen brücken und tunnel vielen
sind drohnen sehr hilfreich sie können
gemeinden mit schwacher infrastruktur
versorgen und das leben in kurzer zeit
dramatisch verändern alex ist in die
zukunft als zweifelsohne selbst am
himmel ist das viel einfacher als am
boden weil es weniger zufällige
ereignisse
weniger bälle die über die straße hüpfen
weniger kinder die auf die straße laufen
[Musik]
in den letzten jahren sind viele neue
firmen in den markt für urbane
luftfahrttechnik eingestiegen sie alle
wollen teil der autonomen revolution
werden
[Musik]
im moment sind das weltweit fast 200
unternehmen und da sind die die heimlich
an sowas arbeiten nicht mitgerechnet und
die gibt's auch
eine firma die chinesische hang hat
schon damit begonnen selbst fliegende
passagiermaschinen zu entwickeln
die chinesen können innerhalb der
eigenen grenzen ideale bedingungen
schaffen würde problematisch wird es
wenn es an den export
die regulierung funktioniert in china
ganz anders als im restlichen asien in
europa oder in den usa im eigenen land
können sie ein ganz anderes tempo
vorlegen als wir im westen ob und wie
das mit unseren vorstellungen
zusammenpasst wissen
es wird schwierig die verschiedenen
vorgaben miteinander zu verbinden das
wird ein politisches thema werden wir
werden sehen wie sich das entwickelt
und wie sieht es mit der zukunft der
orban luftfahrt aus das hängt ehrlich
gesagt von unser
technologie ist da wir wissen was
möglich ist die frage ist nur was wir
wollen
so oder so die art und weise wie wir
fliegen wird sich verändern es ist eine
veränderung die nicht von der
herkömmlichen luftfahrtindustrie
vorangetrieben wird sondern von einer
neuen generation von unternehmern die
keine angst haben anders zu denken
solange wir sagen wenn die lösung nicht
hundertprozentig ist wenn sie nicht für
alle strecken funktioniert kommt sie für
mich nicht in frage heißt dass die augen
vor den problemen zu verschließen
stattdessen müssen wir unser denken
ändern und stück für stück vorgehen wenn
es ein problem gibt dass ich heute lösen
lässt dann lasst uns das angehen
jeder hat die macht selbst aktiv zu
werden mit dieser macht entsteht auch
die verantwortung etwas zu tun
ein park treten bauen etwas in ihrer
garage und zeigen der welt dass es
funktioniert und die komplette
luftfahrtindustrie hat nichts zu geben
es geht mit den kleinen flugzeugen los
mit der zeit werden immer größere dazu
kommt
die technologie ist die einzige lösung
für eine bessere zukunft die zugleich
nachhaltig ist
wenn wir das alles nachhaltig gestalten
können verändern wir unser ganzes leben
und das wird auch zeit
ich wünschte meine zeit in der luftfahrt
würde jetzt anfangen denn es ist eine
wunderbare zeit ein ganz neuer anfang
[Musik]